[Musica]
siamo insomma siamo ragazzi che facciamo
un momento di defaillance benissimo
bene bene allora innanzitutto vogliamo
dire questo allora per noi è davvero un
grande grandissimo onore essere qui nel
senso che stare condividere questo parco
con scienziati artisti innovatori è il
motore che lasciano segni di innovazione
far andare avanti il mondo per noi è
veramente un orgoglio ecco soprattutto
ti mette in contatto con te stesso ti fa
chiedere anche anche anche tu hai
qualcosa da dire cioè anche noi tre
abbiamo qualcosa di interessante da dire
arrivederci
no a parte gli scherzi qualcosa da dire
ce l'abbiamo anche noi e per
raccontarvelo volevamo partire da una
storia una storia ambientata in un
inverno freddo freddissimo
erano giorni che nevicava senza dar
segno di smettere e tutto era diventato
bianco bianchi erano gli alberi bianchi
i fiumi le valli le cime delle montagne
tutto coperto da una foltissima coltre
di neve
perfino gli animali si erano spostati
erano andati a trovare un luogo più
adatto dove trovare del cibo soltanto un
uccellino era rimasto indietro
erano giorni che volava in mezzo a
questi fiocchi di neve cercando
disperatamente un posto dove potersi
appoggiare per riposare soltanto che
dall'alto vedeva tutto quanto bianco a
un certo punto qualcosa atti o la sua
attenzione vide una macchia scura un
puntino nero che saltava all'occhio
allora si abbassò di quota scese più in
basso e si accorse
che si trattava di un sasso una pietra
priva di neve sembrava quasi un dono del
cielo quale posto migliore dove
finalmente potersi riposare
allora si abbassa ancora un po
all'altezza del sasso e con la voce è
smorzata dal freddo e dalla stanchezza
disse sei dal sasso sono giorni che non
riesco ad appoggiarmi da nessuna parte
sono così stanco posso mettermi su di
lei
il sasso lo guardò e rispose ma certo
uccellino era felicissimo poter
finalmente appoggiarsi sul sasso
togliersi la neve dalle zampette sporche
riposare le sue ali e dopo qualche
istante spiccare il volo e riprendere il
suo viaggio
grazie mille era l'unico su cui poteva
appoggiarmi ci sarò per sempre debitore
ma il sas alzò la mano
sorrise tranquillo lo vide allontanarsi
in mezzo ai fiocchi di neve e disse
grazie a te ora non mi chiederò più
perché sono qui ecco molto ben santo ci
tenevo ringraziare i miei colleghi per
la stupenda interpretazione
vi starete chiedendo perché vi abbiamo
cazzo
[Musica]
no dicevo vi starete chiedendo perché vi
abbiamo raccontato questa storia
esatto il fatto è questo quando ci hanno
chiesto di partecipare a questo ted qua
a san marino
noi ci siamo interrogati più giorni su
che cosa volevamo dire cioè cosa ci
sembrava più giusto comunicate c'era chi
per chi voleva parlare di teatro
chi raccontare la nostra storia e chi
invece la propria perversione per gli
animali di piccola taglia
comunque è fatto sta che effettivamente
non abbiamo proprio le idee chiare su
che cosa volevamo dire allora certamente
questa storia che tutti e tre
condividevamo che ci ha permesso più che
altro di aprire una riflessione su un
fatto che ci è accaduto abbastanza
recentemente noi siamo tre attori
diplomati all'accademia d'arte
drammatica paolo grassi di milano
forse qualcuno si conoscerà perché
abbiamo partecipato all'ultima edizione
della trasmissione italia's got talent
che il dopo che abbiamo vinto questa
questa trasmissione e noi ci siamo
sbronza t che ci siamo visti il giorno
dopo dopo che ci siamo ripresi sì ma non
c è ci siamo ci siamo guardati in faccia
noi ci siamo detti ragazzi ma abbiamo
vinto un talent show ma questo cosa
significa no perché allora vuol dire che
abbiamo un talent no però c'era qualcuno
che dicevano al talent non ce l'avete
voi c'era qualcun altro tarda ora
dicevamo allora esistono dei detentori
del talete c'è qualcuno che il pala
c'era qualcuno che non ce l'ha e allora
non ci siamo chieste ma che cos'è il
talent si è effettivamente noi ci siamo
interrogati sul concetto e sul
significato proprio di questa parola
talento e ci siamo resi conto che in fin
dei conti è una parola che a noi non è
mai stata così chiara forse è un
problema che abbiamo fin da piccoli
versi mi ricorda che da bambino in
quinta elementare avevo questo ragazzino
compagno di classe e alberto dieci anni
che lui era bravissimo in tutte le
materie
ma non era uno di quelli che che doveva
studiare per delle ore gli bastavano
pochi minuti per prendere ottimo in
tutte le materie e mia mamma come tutte
le altre mamme dicevano guarda questo è
un talento questo qua da grandi
diventerà qualcun altro poi chiara
alessandro che lui era bravissimo a
correre
era il più veloce di tutta la scuola e
sapeva a memoria tutte le regole di
tutti gli sport e li sapevano a
praticare anche benissimo che io manco
sapevo giocare a carte cioè per farvi
capire poi c'era massimiliano che al
talento delle arti marziali saranno il
talento della poesia giulia volta eletto
da pittura arcobaleni realizzazione non
è che ci devi fare l'appello adesso
comunque noi non abbiamo anche capito
cosa voleva dirci a colpetto quale io
sentivo di non avere nessun talento
ah no ecco questa è una cosa che capita
in tante persone ma perché forse io
chiedo tu cercavi il tuo talento
confrontando di agli altri cioè tu
cercavi appunto il talento sperando di
essere migliore di qualcuno ma perché
forse proprio questo proprio che c'è un
fraintendimento sul concetto di talento
perché è sempre legato a un discorso di
confronto di paragone sono d'accordo il
talento sembra essere qualcosa che
appartiene a pochi pochi eletti
quindi chi ha più talento è quello che
avrà successo è il più bravo acquisisce
sempre un valore di migliore o peggiore
esatto e noi ci chiediamo ma è soltanto
questo il talento cioè nel senso è
proprio e solo quella cosa che
identifica il migliore in un determinato
campo
se no devo incontrare la zia come
qualsiasi tipo di appunto di dubbio noi
leggeremo la definizione di talento
direttamente dal dizionario mese daniele
la dieta classico ma funziona sempre il
segno talento ecologici in mente cosa
antica moneta in circolazione in grecia
e in palestina ai tempi di gesù e 159
allora ci direbbe se la slide eccolo qua
talento letteralmente volontà voglia
desiderio intorno mi guardò come talento
avesse di vedersi altri era amico
bellissimo petrarca dante
e poi e poi più sotto attenzione andare
a talento nel senso andare a genio
disposizione d'animo ingegno
predisposizione ecco bella quest'ultima
parola mi piace il genio predisposizione
per predisposizione c'è proprio la
predisposizione che qualcuno ha nei
confronti di qualcosa il fatto che una
persona riesce a fare una cosa meglio di
un'altra cosa e non è il fatto che una
persona riesca a fare meglio una cosa
rispetto a un altro paragone non c'entra
niente no è proprio una buona
propensione nel fare qualcosa ma tutti e
tutti c'erano diverse a chi per fare
l'artista chi il matematico chi per le
lingue e chi per fare la mamma che per
il papa e chi per zappare la terra
insomma tutti hanno una predisposizione
un salento punto thomas e è quella cosa
che ti fa dire io so dove vorrei andare
ma ma non conosco la strada poi magari
gli utenti in paio poi davanti dei b b
dove va dalla destra va da sinistra che
faccio la rotonda faccio in versione web
poi c'è traffico di gatti perché già
traffico e poi il piano toccato ma era
un graffietto maioni daniele daniele
quella è la
insomma se abbiamo un po perso la
direzione ecco del nostro ragionamento
allora forse è il caso di attingere a
qualcuno che ne sa un pochino più di noi
per andare avanti con l'approfondimento
questo da un certo allora vogliamo
condividere con voi alcune riflessioni
di uno psicologo junghiano e filosofo
che si chiama james hillman eccolo qua
james hillman associa il concetto di
talento al concetto di daimon daimon è
una parola di origine greca che
significa appunto demone anima essere
divino il daimon diciamo era una figura
che proveniva da un altrove non era né
umano né di vino stava diciamo in mezzo
alle due cose qui stiamo capendo dal
dizionario che il talento è qualcosa che
appartiene a tutti non è qualcosa che
appartiene soltanto a pochi eletti
e adesso il man ci dice che il talento
coincide proprio con l'anima delle
persone
c'era una volta una ragazzina di 17 anni
americana nata in virginia
trascorre la sua infanzia tra
orfanotrofi e quartieri malfamati di new
york questa ragazzina un sogno che è
quello di diventare una grande ballerina
così un giorno si decide di partecipare
ad un concorso di artisti alla pollo
harlem theatre
siamo nel 1933
e il suo momento il suo momento arrivato
tutto è pronto si trova nel teatro la
ragazza prima di lei esce tra gli
applausi applausi del pubblico no
il palcoscenico è tutto suo lei
finalmente si accinge a salire sul
palcoscenico gli occhi concentrati a
ripassare la coreografia e le luci si
accendono la musica parte è lei il sale
sul palco e si blocca un'improvvisa
crisi di nervi
le impedisce qualsiasi movimento il
presentatore sale sul palco la intima di
continuare di non lasciare in pubblico
così a bocca asciutta
lei è sempre più tesa è sempre più tesa
una lacrima sta per scoppiare in volto
quando la vera essenza il talento di
questa ragazzina esce e comincia a
cantare con una voce incredibile
il presentatore senza parole il pubblico
in delirio finisce e finisce
l'esibizione e viene dichiarata la
vincitrice del concorso
ed è proprio qui al harlem theatre nel
1933 che ha inizio la carriera di una
delle più grandi cantanti jazz di tutti
i tempi è la jane fitzgerald
st
shining quindi il talento si identifica
perfettamente con la nostra anima con il
nostro demone il nostro compito nella
nostra vita è quello di farle emergere
di esprimerlo perché quando non lo
assecondi e ti obbliga a seguire una
strada
all'apparenza più comoda che magari
conosci già cosa succede che dentro di
te tutte le emozioni tutte le tue
sensazioni si aggrovigliano e stai male
allora ti puoi bloccare può esplodere in
rabbia o può entrare nel panico però in
ogni caso anche se non lo senti dentro
di te c'è qualcosa che urla
noi ci siamo accorti che la tendenza
soprattutto nei giovani le nostre più o
meno coetanei grazie anche all'avvento
dei social è quella di tendere
all'omologazione
diciamo che si soffre come la sindrome
del brutto anatroccolo ci si sente
brutti goffi inadatti inadeguati
sbagliati e invece di difendere ciò che
siamo
si aspira ad assomigliare a dei modelli
che consideriamo migliori e che ci
condannano a vivere con un senso di
inferiorità costante si aspira a piacere
agli altri
indistintamente invece case stessi e
così comincia questa ricerca ossessiva
di like di mi piace e di consensi nel
tentativo disperato di essere accettati
e apprezzati dalla società
questa cosa si fa invece dimenticare
sempre di più quello che siamo veramente
qual è il nostro talento la nostra anima
il nostro demone la nostra preziosa
diversità e allora adesso noi ci
chiediamo tutti insieme ma perché tutto
sto pippone sul talento del regio lino
perché ce lo siamo chiesti insomma ecco
perché secondo noi il talento è
un'opportunità che ognuno di noi sa di
poter vivere la propria vita con un
senso di pienezza dando un senso al
proprio essere qui proprio come il sasso
con l'uccellino e non riguarda soltanto
il mestiere che uno fa riguarda proprio
la persona che sei il modo in cui ti
poni nella vita e non permettere agli
altri
chi sceglierà il nostro posto quello che
siamo o quello che vogliamo diventare
perché secondo noi è proprio da questo
che dipende la nostra felicità e il
nostro equilibrio felicità e infelicità
che sono direttamente secondo noi
proporzionali al quanto uno si sente
realizzato per essere felici secondo noi
sì bisogna essere realizzati ma è essere
realizzati che cosa significa attenzione
perché non significa aver raggiunto un
determinato tipo di successo può essere
arrivati in qualsiasi posto nella vita
essere realizzati significa diventare
reali verificarsi guardarsi per davvero
noi siamo realizzati quando cominciamo
ad ascoltare l'urlo che dentro di noi
siamo realizzati quando saliamo su un
palcoscenico convinti di dover ballare
ci blocchiamo entriamo nel panico e
scopriamo che siamo fatti per cantare
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]